foreign
[Music]
to you guys the strange connection
between Godzilla and his arch enemy
destoroya how the enemy kaiju's
existence is tied to Godzilla from the
very beginning and how destroy his DNA
in his final perfect form is related to
The Big G in a way he has bought
Godzilla just like biolante space
Godzilla and Olga so let's talk a bit
about his Origins his design and all
that stuff that links him up with the
G-Man let's get to it
firstly let's talk about the first
connection with Godzilla his Origins and
then later we will tell you how he is in
a way blood related to the king of the
monsters
so destroy is actually an amalgamation
of billions or trillions of microscopic
creatures it All Began billions of years
ago when these microscopic Crustaceans
lived in the ocean floor unknown to the
world they persisted through the eons
hibernating and locked within the
ancient strata beneath Tokyo bay then in
1954 Dr sarizawa unleashed the
devastating power of the oxygen
Destroyer to kill the first Godzilla
inadvertently altering the fate of these
ancient creatures this event brought
them back to life and catalyzed a
transformation like none other
so over the span of four decades these
revived Crustaceans underwent a
remarkable Evolution they absorbed the
micro oxygen release from the
destructive weapon the oxygen Destroyer
which was only intended to only put an
end to Godzilla this forever changed
their biological Essence altering their
DNA and making them rapidly evolve to
overcome the modern environment then the
construction of the Tokyo bay aqualine
disrupted their Subterranean Sanctuary
forcing them to the surface now with
their natural state Changed by the
weapon meant to kill Godzilla these
creatures began to emerge out and melt
and mold to increasingly monstrous forms
growing deadlier with each passing stage
so you can say that the death of
Godzilla brought destoroia to life in a
way at least philosophically or
metaphorically
destoroya undergoes a stunning set of
evolutionary phases and Transformations
throughout the entire length of the
movie it starts with its micro form
unseen but envisioned to resemble like
those ancient extinct trilobites then we
have the second form or the crawl form
resembling a red miniature horseshoe
crab boasting spikes and mandibles and a
pointed tail with the juvenile form the
third one Destroyer gains crap like legs
terrifying shoulder spikes and glowing
orange eyes showcasing its growing
manners the aggregate form enlarges the
juvenile form adding chess clause and
spear-like appendages in its flying form
it adopts wing-like lobes for flight
donning a deadly mouth and a distinctive
forehead horn finally The Towering
perfect form stands upright featuring
bad like wings formidable arms with
three Claws and a menacing pincer tail
epitomizing is formidable ever-evolving
threat
but as you can see there is a stark
difference between the crustacean like
aggregate form which is the fourth form
and The Reptilian perfect form which is
the fifth form but how did this
Evolution take place when we can see
that the Juvenile and the flying form
compared to the aggregate form don't
really have that much of a difference
aside from possessing an extra pair of
Limbs but the fifth or the perfect
Destroyer form seems to have a body akin
to Godzilla in a way with muscular legs
instead of arthropod like limbs with
forearms a bulky body and a very long
muscular tail it seems that it changed
from a crustacean to a reptile well the
answer to that is that the fifth form
has Godzilla DNA in it while the
previous ones did not
this is the second and more deeper
connection destroya has with Godzilla
while his Origins has a metaphorical
link to Godzilla the fifth form actually
has the g-man's blood in him which
explains the uncanny resemblance in body
structure and the emergence of new
powers in him so the deed was in Tokyo
when the aggregate form fought with
Godzilla Junior and sang its secondary
jaw into Junior's chest delivering a
little dose of micro oxygen into
Junior's bloodstream causing him to form
at the mouth and struggle to breathe
kind of like suffocating however
Godzilla Jr summoned his strength and
retaliate it unleashing his Atomic
breath to severe destroyer's back Claws
and force it to release him
following this junior continued his
assault setting destroy hurling into a
nearby Refinery resulting in a fiery
explosion but Destroyer was not dead and
in fact when he injected the micro
oxygen into Godzilla Junior's body like
a mosquito he also sucked Junior's blood
and with that he attained the DNA and he
used it to mutate further hence
transforming into the terrifying perfect
form which was only possible with the
DNA of the king of the monsters himself
and that is the real connection he has
with the G-Man so you can say he is sort
of a Godzilla hybrid in a way less so
compared to space Godzilla but more in
the lines of biolante and Orga who also
had Godzilla DNA to mutate and develop
into their perfect forms
so those are the two strange connections
between Godzilla and destoroya so in
conclusion destroys Origins and Ultimate
Evolution all depended on Godzilla and
without Godzilla he would have been
crustacean till the end anyway I hope
you have enjoyed watching this video do
hit the like button for support and
subscribe to push us through in the
YouTube algorithm but most of all smash
that Bell icon for regular updates on
new videos right here on this channel
till next time take care fam